our Series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us when it
comes to making friends high school can
be especially difficult for some
teenagers the hardest part of the day
can be lunchtime in the high school
cafeteria CBS this morning Saturday
co-host Dana Jacobson visited Boiling
Springs High School in South Carolina to
see how a simple question changed one
student's life tell me about the first
day of school this year I was sitting at
lunch like I normally did you know and
they came up to me and asked me to sit
with man who was they who came up to you
the student council what did you think
when they came up I was excited
excitement might not be the typical
reaction for a high school student but
lunch has never been very social for
sophomore Andrew Kirby last year what
was lunch like I was seeing like a 1 a
lot of times at lunch I'll text Andrew K
Kirby is Andrews mom and I said are you
eating with anyone and he said no and I
sat at my desk at work and I just prayed
I said lord please send somebody to eat
with him making friends hasn't been easy
for Andrew he was born with a
neurological disorder and has undergone
several major surgeries you hear that
he's sitting alone as a mom how did that
make you feel broke my heart but that
changed on the first day of school when
members of the student council noticed
that Andrew was eating alone and invited
him to join them
we were sitting by ourselves we wanted
someone so we don't want someone to have
this about themselves everyone needs
have someone anyone can get over that
it's very encouraging to know that
they're there teenagers out there that
took their time thank you
they weren't being in their own clique
they weren't being selfish they took
their time to reach out just somebody
that might be different and you know you
never know what a child's going through
maybe they've got a bad home life maybe
they're depressed you know and there's a
kid sitting by themselves and they
notice that the peace I have now at
lunch I don't feel like I need to text
him to check on him what started as a
small act of kindness has even gone
beyond the cafeteria they went to the
movies together a couple weeks ago and
he had never really been invited by
other kids his age to go out and hang
out as a 16 year old what did that mean
to you like it mean it's still special
that someone who asked me to go a
special gesture that would have a
lasting impact have you been eating
lunch with them every day since yeah
you're not hearing from Andrew around
lunch anymore no he had takes me since
for CBS this morning Dana Jacobson
Boiling Springs South Carolina Dana
that's great so many things start in the
school cafeteria they sure do
kindness of only a mother to him do they
coming you could come and love it